[Music]
so this is a very unique space to give a
Tech Talk I definitely didn't expect
this as I was going in when we were
making the slides I told the design team
that I thought the minimum font size was
too small and they like you know what
Chad don't worry about it the image is
gonna be big enough if you really like
the talk you can stick around adventures
is on it's 7:00 and then at 9 o'clock
it's the Incredible Hulk
my name is Chad Jennings thank you for
joining us make yourself comfortable
this is the plushest set of seats i've
ever seen for a Tech Talk and for the
next 47 minutes we're going to be
talking about HSBC's migration journey
into bigquery
there's no laser pointer all right so
I'll just gesture to elements on the
slide and hopefully that will work out
you can see from the list of speakers
that we've got quite a crew up here and
the reason we need this many people to
tell this story is that it's actually
quite a significant story right when the
world's largest financial institution
migrates from on-prem into the cloud
they're gonna have some very specific
requirements and very specific
regulations to which they need to adhere
and that's going to require them to do
some really innovative things and the
HSBC HSBC team has really risen to the
challenge and they've invented some new
technology and we're gonna describe that
and describe their their journey to the
cloud so if there are folks here who are
interested in data warehouse migrations
I think you'll find this material very
interesting so the cast of characters
are the following so my name is Chad I
am a product manager for bigquery and
then Yong is a colleague of mine from
the professional services organization
and he has been moving along with srini
and Santa in lockstep for about the last
year to make this migration happen so
the the quartet of us not the Beatles
this quartet are going to take you
through the story so here's how we're
going to roll it out do a little bit of
an introduction and some announcements
we've got some new stuff coming out was
mentioned in the Kino
but we'll go into those in a little bit
more detail in this session and then
srini is going to come up and talk about
the migration principle scope and
strategy that HSBC developed to guide
the execution which is what Yong and
Sansa will talk about and then we'll
kind of end it with oh my goodness why
why oh why would you do this thing like
what are the benefits that you get out
of it because it's not it's not a it's
not a miniscule amount of work
all right so intros and announcements
first we are aware that there folks
who will be joining on YouTube so maybe
they haven't all folks watching the
video may not have all seen bigquery so
if you know what bigquery is there are
two slides of introduction so pull out
your cell phone just you know put it on
mute but like you know watch a YouTube
video really really quiet or check your
email but in two minutes I'll call you
back you don't know what bigquery is
then for the next two minutes you are my
people
bigquery is Google clouds enterprise
data warehouse for analytics the core
things you need to know about it is it
goes super fast over super big sets of
data and it also goes super fast over
small sets of data and you really don't
need to worry about whether your data is
big or small we'll handle that part of
it for you you use sequel to interact
with it actually I have to update the
slide because after the keynote
yesterday you use sequel and connected
sheets to interact with bigquery so
sequel speakers and spreadsheet speakers
can now interact with bigquery directly
and most important to them on this slide
is that it's fully managed and
serverless and what does that mean all
right so in the huge donut on the left
you'll see a whole bunch of tasks in
gray and these are tasks that system
administrators or database
administrators need to conduct to keep
their data warehouse now fully fed
watered content happy and performing so
from performance tuning to patch
upgrades reliability monitoring etc that
is all stuff that Google handles for you
if you're a big query customer or any of
our fully managed service services we
take care of that for you leaving you to
worry about your business right what
what analysis do you want to do what
insights do you want to try to pull out
of your data we'll handle the rest
all right that was 1 minute and 42
seconds and I know because I'm watching
on the clock so if you've been off
checking your email come on back now
because this next this next set is for
you so Google Cloud it's part of the
information superhighway and a fair and
reasonable criticism that Google has had
to withstand is hey your services are
fantastic it's you know that's the
information superhighway but would you
please pave the on-ramps and so that's
what we're discussing here today with
the announcement of the data warehouse
migration service so this is an agent or
a tool that you can use to automatically
move data and schema from on-prem to
bigquery and not have to not have to
manage that process or not have to
manage the details of that
transformation in the schema migration
by hand the way it works is at the top
left box here is that the source right
the on-premise system you actually
download an agent onto a VM in your
source system that then configures the
migration it looks into your tables the
metadata in your tables and figures out
what some of what the relationships are
and then post that back to GCP and says
ok I understand what the schema should
be inside a big query let's move it and
then transfers the data over into
bigquery using the bigquery data
transfer service and then loads that
straight into bigquery as the same
schema and it transforms data types etc
as the same schema that you started with
in teradata
so we are very excited about this tool
we want our partners to use it we want
our customers to use it to make it a lot
easier to get their data from the
on-prem system to the new one of note we
should say that the the supported
sources right now our Teradata redshift
and s3 and we're going to be expanding
this list as the beta continues we also
have some announcements around
individual features so these were
contained in the in the keynote but
let's just spend a moment on him here
they're relevant for data warehouse
migrations because if you move
say Teradata to bigquery but bigquery
doesn't have all the features that
you're accustomed to in Teradata there
it won't be the same rich experience as
you're accustomed to like what the
breaks taken off so we are very aware
that we need to make sure that you have
things like integer range partitioning
scripts and stored procedures those are
all in alpha right now the bigquery
storage API is another very significant
launch that's gone to beta and that
actually allows either you or any
analysis tool to get direct access to
bigquery storage in an exceedingly
performant way in an unlimited way as
well right now export jobs are limited
to 10 terabytes per day with the storage
API you can extract as much data as you
need
so this speeds up things like
visualization tools or data flow and
data proc jobs that are running on data
stored in bigquery the goal of that API
actually is to make it so that bigquery
is the place to store all your
structured data because you can get to
it with any analysis tool you want to
once it's inside of bigquery and then
launching to your general availability
clustering is going G a1 GA yesterday
bigquery GIS and the merge statement so
you can see by our efforts here that
we've wearest we are continually
improving bigquery so that when you
migrate your data from one to the next
that you have all the features and all
of the speed and velocity that you need
in the cloud one of the things that I
think the bigquery team does
particularly well and yes I'm biased but
I'm gonna say it anyway is it we try to
engage very very deeply with our
customers at scale we have a public
issue tracker and we track issues that
pub the the public reports to us and so
up votes and the public issue tracker
does move things up in our roadmap so I
encourage you all to use that and upload
the features that you want us to make
next for for platinum customers like
HSBC we actually get into the weeds and
design our betas and GA requirements for
the for the requirements that our
customers have I won't read through all
of these features that that HSBC is
using inside of bigquery but I'll point
to the one on the bottom right so
customer managed encryption keys we
actually designed the
availability launch requirements to
match what hsbc hsbc needed so that we
could get to GA faster for the use case
that we needed support which was to
please this very important customer any
case so with that I'm gonna kind of tie
the bow in the intro and announcements
and you know talking about the features
that HSBC is using is the perfect segue
over to Serena from HSBC hello everyone
good afternoon this looks like a movie
star for me you know I just wanted to be
a speaker and Google medium made me a
movie star here so very well okay so my
name is Srinivas Reddy and I'm a
delivery manager at HSBC so I lead the
data on cloud program and my team
supports the cloud migration initiatives
so coming to the I just want to start
with a quick intro on HSBC I think many
of you already know which has been C but
just to give you some numbers here we
have around 39 million customers spread
across 66 countries so coming to the
data assets part we have been growing
rapidly and as of 2018 we have around
169 petabytes of data compared to 2014
we had 56 petabytes it is 300% increase
and your data curve data centers in 21
countries and more than 94 thousand plus
servers and some of the statistics on
the slide there so going to the cloud
journey so HSBC has started the cloud
journey with Google about two and a half
to three years back in 2017 we started
our development environments and we
started you know working on the
different requirements understanding
Google capabilities and mapping them to
our needs and by end of 2017 we had a
contract with Google and Google was
selected as a strategic partner for data
and analytics services going going ahead
in 2018 we started building our Google
cloud foundation platform and that just
BC being a very highly regulated
industry
we need to make sure that we adhere to
all the dignitary policies and also make
sure that our data is secure at rest in
motion and also we have the complete
control of data so in this regard we
worked with Google collaborated with
them coordinate with them and as Chad
said some of the features you have seen
in the previous slide who are
implemented for us to make sure that in
our data is secure and we don't have any
data leakages that attack detects
filtrations so those services are the
customer managed encryption key
the VPC service controls and the access
transparency logs these were really
helping us to make sure that you know we
have complete security and we don't have
any data leakage or attacks filtration
and he also helped us to get the
approvals to move sensitive data to
Google cloud in parallel in 2018 we
started analyzing about data warehouses
to see which of them can move to cloud
and in this slide you know you can see
this verall for critical data analytic
workload which we are currently
migrating to cloud as you can see there
view being a big international company
we have this data warehouse present in
more than one country at least 10
countries here so our approach is that
we would like to be started with UK and
there is a most complex data warehouse
and we have we are created a template
for that and we use this template for
migration of other countries variable
the regulators allow us and Google Cloud
is present there so what are the primary
challenges we are trying to address here
so as many other large organizations
such as BC has a rapid and tremendous
growth of data and all the constraints
are seeing is capacity on-prem we are
not able to you know either you have to
increase the very infrastructure to meet
all the data coming in and to meet our
analytical needs or we need to look at
other options and that's of course
there's a cloud secondly the business is
really constrained because I talked
about 169 petabyte of data but
the use of data if you are not able to
get the business the valuable insights
they want so because of capacity and
processing constraints we are unable to
really service our customers as we want
to and other challenge is that these
warehouses have been built over 15 years
of time and we have challenges to the
metadata but data lineage and that are
causing a duplication of data as well as
data quality issues so to address this
particular thing you know particular
challenges we wanted know we started our
journey to cloud so the first use case
have taken is a UK data analytic
workload so here you can see the you
know Vanek when I say data warehouse
it's just not a simple data warehouse
but it's a combination of ecosystem of
you know the ETL jobs reporting jobs and
scheduling jobs and oolitic users using
this data for multiple purposes right
it's not a simple thing distribute some
members to hear numbers to you here this
particular UK data analytic workload has
more than 6500 ETL jobs and more than
2,500 reports it gets data from about
hundred sources it has 180 terabytes of
data and a rich history of 30 years with
millions of customers and transactions
and also it supports regulatory
reporting likely created reporting and
FATCA reporting so this is a huge and a
complex critical data warehouse for HSBC
and when we embarked this journey of
moving this to cloud we seek the help of
Google so Google partnered with us to
evaluate multiple options so evaluated
options like engineering lift and shift
and finally we zeroed in on what we call
it as move and improve so what do you
mean by move and improve so we want to
move our data warehouse to bigquery get
all the capabilities and all the know
all the capacity and all the elasticity
etcetera of a query and that helps us to
solve the capacity constraints that's
where we are trying to solve immediately
because that's where we need to either
invest more
on Prem or go to Google Cloud and to
improve on that we have to employ
challenges so I talked about some of the
challenges like metadata and data
lineage so now we are taking this as
about next task and adding metadata data
lineage etcetera over our warehouse on
Google there's a big query and making it
more simple as far as the ETL jobs are
concerned and reporting jobs are
concerned we talked about the numbers
there the staggering numbers of 6500
plus and so on so we took a conscious
nation that know the primary concern or
challenge we're trying to solve is
capacity so we'll go with go ahead with
a infrastructure service option for our
ETL jobs and reporting jobs and take our
ETL and reporting as these to Google and
also where as we are taking this journey
we looked at how can we simplify this
particular concrete Magnusson so what we
did is no we because this data warehouse
was built over the last fifteen years
you know believe it or nor if it would
have a good inventory of it so we
started looking at what applications
what reports exist on this bit of air
house and how we can actually look at
water which of them are used and unused
right so we worked as of stakeholders
and identified about 600 plus reports
are not being used at all so we
immediately said because this can be
devised
similarly we working with stakeholders
and business stakeholders to understand
which of the applications are not used
and which can be which can be no not
migrated and looked at demising of those
so in that way we are only migrating the
applications and reports which we want
to migrate and in this journey of you
also looking at simplifying our ETL jobs
and taking off the technical debt of
previous migrations so a production
support can have a better sleep at night
coming to the core data first so we took
the approach of you know moving the code
data code tables first this gives us the
data foundation because once we move a
code data and tables on Google we give
opportunity for the next the new use
cases coming in to use this data and
develop in Google native and also we are
looking at
agile and fail fast so we have we are in
this transformation journey
hSBC has been information journey of a
child and devops for some time now and
this project is completely Agilent
DevOps so we have always looked at how
we can deliver smaller workloads and not
a bigger ones and how we can actually
use a fail fast so that we can actually
build some patterns and proof of
concepts and achieve the target what we
want and one important thing I want to
talk about is innovation and automation
from day one of our journey we took this
very seriously we wanted to make sure we
automate everything I mean like you know
automate everything possible these very
much required because we are looking at
a massive migration here and if you go
with the manual effort will not be able
to meet our timelines and you know as
any other project we have strict
timelines to meet because you know
otherwise we have to buy new
infrastructure or renew new licenses but
you don't want to do so with this you
know with this mantra of you know
automation we went ahead and created
multiple accelerators and some of these
accelerators are the data reconciliation
tool which reconciles between the source
and the target using hash algorithm at a
record level and make sure that the
payload is delivered from social target
without any loss and there is a
discrepancy we can actually look at in
our reporting and production support can
fix that develop one more accelerator
called the sequel passer so many of you
know that you know when we look at a
native data data warehouse we are native
sequels and they are not one or two but
thousands of them in our case there were
3,500 sequels so we don't want to
migrate them one by one so we did a pass
automatic passer which migrates the or
the sequels of native into a bigquery
compatible sequels third one is data
lineage tool the very critical tool for
us because as many of you know these
warehouses have been developed for last
15 years so there is no data lineage
there is no documentation so this tool
helps us to have a lineage between the
reporting to the data warehouse to the
source so it helps us to prioritize our
workloads as you are running our sprints
we wanted migrate to say X number of
reports we know which data which tables
had we migrated before we can go to the
reports and is a also useful for a
stakeholder management and as I told you
the Google partnership has been a great
help for us in this so as we did the
decision of moving our ETL jobs and
reporting as a infrastructure as a
service to Google I think the first time
anyone is doing that in the entire world
so we face challenges with technical
challenges which we have to resolve and
that's where we start to Google and
Google partnered with us in not only
helping us to understand the challenges
but also helping us to do proof of
concepts and building patterns and these
patterns are very useful for us because
these helped us to really put a factory
migration in place and not really a one
by one but we have a factory running now
we actually migrate the ETLs
by punches and by chunks depending on of
workload of migration so at this point
of time I would like to invite Ian puker
who is a Google PSO lead and has been
with us philosopher near helping has not
said accelerators of this automation and
my colleague sent a car maker who is my
senior tech lead technical architect as
BC to take us a little deeper into this
accelerators and technical challenges
Center and Ian thank you very much srini
even though our thoughts numbers many
many times it's still impressive
especially in such a big screen so yeah
hi al
hi everyone my name is Yann I'm a
strategic cloud engineer in the
professional service organization of
Google in Singapore freshness services
helps our customers with biggest and
most complicated technical problems
usually through consulting and
engineering and very often together with
partners so before I go into the details
let me quickly explain how those kind of
data warehouse migrations typically work
so there's two kind of types of
customers as to ones who just want zero
impact on the on the operations and the
ideally wants an automated tool and just
want to have
that done for them even if it in an
opinionated way that's for instance what
chat introduced to us to be created
emigration services that's great
and understa the other type of customers
who want to leverage as much as possible
on the cloud even if it means
reengineering and that's what we need
called the cloud native approach now as
we heard hsbc is right in the middle and
that's why they engage professional
services because they're moving improve
approach we need to break that down a
little bit more so in order to visualize
that a little bit I'm going to show you
a classic reference architecture very
briefly for data warehouses so those
three boxes boxes are always great boxes
mean architecture diagram on the Left we
have for instance an ingestion layer in
the middle you have processing and
staging and on the right you have view
of reporting and analytics normally so
if we would go in a standard project we
would typically suggest one of our
reference architectures like a reference
architecture for ETL which looks like
this if you have your batch files on
cloud storage you get some events and
streamings who pops up you process that
in cloud dataflow for ETL
but maybe you you're not completely
event based so you still need some
scheduling and some dependency
management in place maybe you even do
eat elt inside so you use cloud composer
for that and all of that goes into our
petabyte scale server less data
warehouse big value now as we nee said
before we couldn't just use that and
Santa is gonna walk us a little bit
through the details of HPC is more
complicated architecture and what
exactly we did to resolve Thank You Yin
hello everyone my name is Shan todas
karmakar I'm a senior lead architect in
HSBC India I am really privileged and
honored to say a few of my experience in
this journey with you all today
the current platform is pretty complex
it has numerous types of feed to be
process n number of tools are in use and
many different complex interfaces with
various trusted source system as Yun
said it has three layer ingestion layer
processing layer and reporting layer
once the various feed from the trusted
source systems arrived at the staging
areas this
network in works a cell script job it
first inserts a record into a job
control list table this table has lot of
inserts and update operations after that
ETL tool performs lot of complex
transformations following business rules
few such transformations like
deduplication of records then historical
data processing based on slowly changing
dimension snapshot load key generations
key lookup etc at the end of the
processing it generates a load ready
file this file gets inserted into error
system via various DB utilities we first
create the core warehouse table which
comprises the 360-degree view of the
customer after that various aggregation
tables forms the semantic layer since
the current architecture is pretty
complex we could not use the reference
architecture as is exactly Thank You
Santa so if you have such a complicated
system what you need to do is break down
the work now again there's two options
to break down your work the classical
enterprise architecture approaches would
be either to go system by system or data
by data system by system meaning you go
through all of your dependent systems
and you just check which ones have to be
migrated and you basically you make a
list of all of your dependent
applications and of your sources and the
data driven approach is a little bit
more you go into the schemas themselves
and then you find out which schemas are
used and then you migrate data by data
incremental e now in this particular
project as Sweeney said before we
decided actually against those two
approaches because we wanted to have a
real business priority and the business
impact
so rather we decided to go with
architecture decision records and those
would be based on technical user
journeys so in order to develop those
technical user journeys we basically did
an agile but I guess all of you have
seen this as basically looks like a
scrum board you can imagine those to be
user stories so I'm going to give you a
few examples of those user stories hours
that we used were much much further
broken down but for the ones who know
data warehouses some of those words Mike
already make sense
to you we have mentioned for instance
change data capture for like event
handling we had slowly shiny dimensions
but sometimes also called data loads
story Delta load or or incremental load
those are the typical data warehouse
topics that you just need to address if
you go such a through such a migration
but we had some other topics which were
more specific to the financial services
industry centers briefly spoke about
deduplication to make sure that the data
warehouse has a very very consistent
golden source of data at a specific
point in time that you need to maintain
but our impact framework didn't only
based on the migration impact for
instance we also looked at the business
impacts we prioritized the archival data
and historic data because that allowed
us to move already things into the cloud
and therefore take load of the old
system making the old system faster for
the users as well as the new system and
other impact was a cultural and
organizational impact something as
trivial as SQL status codes can be very
important for your production support
teams so we made sure that everyone
knows them that we get the right metrics
the right observability very early on in
the process to also start to explain
people that they don't have to manage
hardware anymore but now have to manage
queries and slots and performance and
quotas and look at very different
metrics and that's a that's a change das
takes humans along a time so we wanted
to get that started very early in the
process so once we had those technical
user journeys defined we broke them
further down into pocs and develop
different options for those for those
pocs in those pocs
we looked again at the principles that
Trini mentioned before but now broke
them down a little bit further into
technical principles and Santas can talk
about them again
once the various patterns are identified
we establish few key design principles
which he followed throughout the
execution of the project the current
platform is aging and it has lot of
disruption with the use of various past
surveys such as Google Cloud Storage for
staging area and bigquery for warehouse
we wanted to improve the performance of
the system we want to maintain only
single copy of the data by restricting
multiple copies we improve the
maintenance overhead and also we reduce
the cost the data is always secured with
customer management Christian Keys and
we also applied VPC service control to
prevent the data exfiltration x' our
consumption layer and processing layer
are separated out we have used multiple
authorized views to give access to the
data to various reporting layers and
analytical users with this let me take
you to our data migration strategy or
steps it has three steps number one
migrate the as a schema on to bigquery
and repoint all the analytical and
reporting load on to bigquery step
number two migrate all our historical
data on to bigquery part of the second
step is set up a change data process so
that the warehouse system and bigquery
always remain in sync set up a data
reconciliation tool and use metadata
tagging as a where possible and
applicable third step migrate the data
access layer by converting all the SQL
script into bigquery compliant scripts
this seems to be a very very long and
time-consuming task to speed up the
development and reduce the human errors
we introduced lot of accelerators here
we are going to talk about four
accelerators today
the first two accelerator schema parser
and data reconciliation tool helps us
migrating our data layer on to bigquery
SQL parser helps us migrating the data
access layer onto GCB platform and data
lineage tool provides the dependency
across various component in the pipeline
with that let's look into these tools I
will combine the schema parser and data
reconciliation tool in my next slide and
here it is from the source system we
first extract all the table definition
information and creator of row schema
parse file and then we fetch all the
records from a specific table and we
convert them into Avro format load it
into a data file while doing so we also
apply hashing perform operations and
create a hash data load that data into a
different file along with all the key
elements in it we call this as a
passport file once the hash file with in
the passport file the hash information
and the data files are created we load
this into GCS using gsutil from there we
execute wiki load command to load the
data into bigquery if the tables are not
created first we create the table then
the data gets loaded there once the data
is loaded into bigquery we again apply
the same hashing operation but this time
we do it on bigquery and get the hash
value and then we compare the hash value
with the data what we have received
using the password file whatever these
differences discrepancies are there it
gets reported into our reporting layer
and our production support team finds it
quite useful to correct this data this
tool is quite helpful and very quick
with the help of this step this tool we
could reconcile data for a specific
table in couple of minute which
generally takes almost an hour if I want
to do it manually it has consistent and
repeatable process which eliminates lot
of human errors audit is enable in every
operation in this tool
moving the historical data on to bicker
is quite easy task but when we are
moving the change data on a everyday
basis to sync my own Prem data warehouse
with bigquery we need to set up a change
sed type to operations so that was
little tricky for us when you are
migrating a small table it's just one
step process but if it is a big table we
need to migrate the data chunk by chunk
so once you have migrated the data layer
successfully then we look at how can we
migrate the data access layer what would
be the strategy how can I bring lot of
parallelism that is what cloud is known
for for that yan is going to talk about
it
thanks a lot Sansa so as Santa just said
we couldn't just take the easiest
approach so once we had our technical
user journeys and we had broken down the
decisions we could have just done
different PLC's and decided for whatever
is the easiest but the goal was
Sweeney's goal really was still to move
and improve so we still wanted to get a
faster time to insight we wanted to get
higher availability and higher
performance so we couldn't just accept
tech debt and to illustrate that I'm
quickly going to show an example based
on sargol key generation so in your
regular relational database or data
warehouse you generate surrogate keys
typically using a sequence or some kind
of row identity now we could have also
still generated a sequence but ordering
stuff manually monotonically increasing
is always a bottleneck there are some
academic solutions around that but the
fact is if you do that somewhere it's
going to make stuff slower now bigquery
is fast because they paralyze so we
wanted to find a solution that we can
parallel ice while still maintaining
full consistency of our batch loads and
make sure that reconciliation is
successful so how do we do this we did
this using uu IDs now I used to wear
hash here because we're actually not
using the UUID function in bigquery
we're actually hashing multiple columns
that we define as key columns the trick
here is just actually two tricks one is
we're using the information schema in
the query to find those key columns and
to find the schema itself we work very
early in the alpha and beta programs
together to use the information schema
functionality and the second trick was
to use a merge statement now you would
wonder we're just inserting why do you
want to merge ignoring now the history
processing itself but if I just insert
new values why do I need to merge the
trick here is the merge has an update if
it matches in that update I can throw an
error and now I know exactly which roles
don't match so I don't actually execute
the merge but i throw an error and that
gives me exactly the information which
rows and columns are matched and which
are a problem in there in the actual
process now once we had that solution
and working very fine
we actually found that we could also
solve another problem in some data
warehouses you have a feature that's
called unique set tables it's a rather
obscure feature in my opinion that
allows you to basically ignore errors
you just insert into a table and if
something is already there it doesn't
actually insert it basically
automatically duplicates we don't have
that in bigquery but you could use the
same solution we could just define all
columns as a row identity and then apply
the same process again just in this case
it would be the other way around
we would just not do anything if there
was already a match or insert a new
record this way we could leverage the
full paralyzation of Pickfair even
ingesting the data while still
maintaining a high snapshot isolation
level and the full audit lock and the
full reconciliation capability knowing
at each exact step or B didn't what
happened was that I'm going to go back
to Santa who's going to explain how we
automated that whole process inside the
SQL parser thank a young
so bigquery and on-prem warehouse they
are not same syntactically and
semantically so existing SQL script in
current warehouse does not work as is on
bigquery for example delayed star from a
specific table works perfectly okay in
most of the our DBMS system but in
bigquery does not work you need to add
an additional where Clause at then few
data type such as small int care worker
etcetera there is no direct mapping in
bigquery however good news is in
bigquery you have similar data type with
higher precision example string and in
64 so there is no data loss when you
migrate the data from existing where
problem warehouse on to bigquery the
temp table or volatile table this
construct are actually different in this
two environment SQL person exactly
identify all these scenarios from the
existing SQL script and convert them
into bigquery compliant scripts with
this script we could improve the
performance the development effort by 50
to 60% there are many such scenarios you
have identified while going during the
development phases and we all inter
included them into the SQL parser as and
when you found it it's a very quick tool
easy and super helpful tool with that
let me take you to the last tool for
today's discussion that is data lineage
this tool is actually scrum masters and
project managers delight what it does it
discovers the components from various
layer and identify all the dependent
component starting from the ETL feed to
ETL jobs then warehouse tables and
packages so scrum master finds it quite
useful to identify only the dependent
component which is required for a
specific MVP in a sprint
and allocate the work how it works it
picks up a reporting file as an input
identified the corresponding so tables
from there which ETL job populate those
tables and then what is the ETL feeds
require to populate those ETL jobs a
very super helpful tool with the help of
this tool we could also eliminate the
various integrations issue because the
dependency across various component are
actually identified right at the
planning stage along with that this tool
is also helps us I did for the
stakeholder management's where we have a
big matrix and we know whom to contact
when you are migrating our specific
applications with this I would handed
over to yarn thanks again Santa yeah so
the biggest benefit for us and for me
personally was really that we could work
so closely together we developed or we
developed all of those tools we gained
knowledge we could work together really
on the keyboards and yeah we developed
features as I mentioned before not only
seemed like and vbc service controls but
we worked in information schema the
merge statement all of that hand-in-hand
the other benefits are going to be
covered by Sri Mia again thanks so much
Feeney thank you Center Thank You inter
for the great discussion so um why what
are the benefits of doing this and I
just want to cover that so faster
processing so we all know that you know
you're going to be query now and you
observed that a job which took one hour
or more on trim or less taking less than
10 minutes for us now that means you're
meeting and exceeding SAS the unified
data consumption layer because a Santa
said you're maintaining now a single
copy of data and bigquery creating
authorized views for each consumer that
ensures a parallel on wording for
consuming applications that helps us to
even fit it our development and testing
and the flexible capacity as flexible
scalable capacity as you know bigquery
is scalable and elastic and this
providing the users with great benefits
of you know pay as you consume
so simplified warehouse platform so we
are actually ending up with a much
simplified virus platform as I talked
about the move and improve approach and
the rationalization of applications we
talked about before as well as our the
vias simplifying our ETL jobs as we
migrate so in summary we have taken this
journey of migrating over UK data
warehouse to bigquery or TCP and used
over mu and improve approach for
migration collaborated with Google and
embraced open source and automation has
been our main focus and we are taking
the automation to next level by building
many accelerators and potentially we are
working with Google to open sources
accelerators thank you alright so I hope
everybody heard that last part right
because as I migrations is one of the
p.m. responsibilities that I maintain on
the bigquery team and as I go to talk to
customers about things that are keeping
them up at night or making them worried
about doing a migration reconciliation
and code migration are very much at the
top of the list and so the last point
that's really meant is like the
possibility that HSBC will be able to
open-source these tools I think is
really is going to be really impactful
change so hang on we'll get to that in a
little bit I wanted to I wanted to
invite you all also to ask questions
we've got about five minutes left here
but I wanted to leave kind of with this
with this high-level thought we we've
worked incredibly closely together over
the last three years to get HSBC into
the into the spot that they're in now
and we want to really wanted to motivate
to you all that like as you know Google
is really good at making new technology
happen and customers are really good at
guiding us into saying hey we need
technology to solve this problem no not
that thing over there because that's too
bright and shiny Google we need you to
solve this over here
and and that level of collaboration and
partnership has been really really
valuable for both Google and for our
customers and so I wanted to make that
point here and hopefully you've seen
evidence of that through the story that
the gentlemen here have relayed
[Music]